I have never submitted to analysis I
feel if I knew any secrets about myself
I deprive myself of
writing David Cornwell the real name of
John lare he was 87 when this interview
was done I assumed that this was not
going to be his last interview but it
was I often say that I make movies
because perhaps I can learn something by
making them and I learned an enormous
amount making this
[Music]
movie his real name is David Cornwall
but he's much better known to us as John
lari I'll answer any question you wish
me to answer as truthfully as I can I'm
talking to someone who has published
over 30 novels and I'd read the two most
famous of them Tinker Taylor Soldier Spy
and The Spy Who Came in from the cold
both both really terrific but I read the
pigeon tunnel when I decided that I
would like to try to interview him it's
a strange book it's not really an
autobiography at all it's almost a pasti
of scenes and anecdotes that is really
really beautifully written and truly
compelling I particularly loved the
beginning and the end of it it starts
off with this parable of the pigeon toel
itself and ends with the history of
Rudolph hess's flight to Scotland in
1941 I always saw it as an Excursion
between that beginning and that end that
had been defined in the pigeon tunnel
itself the beginning scene the essence
of this whole project It's a combination
Parable literature history and personal
story here I have all of the this visual
material of people fleeing East Berlin
jumping out of Windows the actual movie
that he created out of this historical
event The Spy Who Came in from the cold
which has images that actually recall
and are recalled by the documentary
footage moral philosophers measuring
everything they do against the word of
God or KL Marx they're not they're just
a bunch of seedy squalled bastards like
me and then the parable so is a young
man he's taken to Monte Carlo by his
father and at the casino they raise
pigeons on the roof their job was to
flutter their way along the pitch dark
tunnel until they emerged in the
Mediterranean sky as targets for the
well- lunched sporting gentlemen who
were standing in wait with their
shotguns sometimes killing them
sometimes wounding them sometimes the
pigeons ES escape and return to the roof
and then are sent out the following day
to do the whole thing over again that
story is the essence of John lare a kind
of copian repetitive activity you do it
again and again and again and it
invariably culminates with death it's a
very powerful
story when I was first in Army
intelligence I conducted a lot of
interviews which were also
interrogations are interviews
interrogations are interrogations
interviews what's the difference really
it's something I thought endlessly
about as a filmmaker I was often
involved in firstperson interviews where
only one person was being interviewed
and the idea was to get them to talk and
reveal something about themselves it
wasn't as if I had an agenda and there
is a difference you work as a spy so
someone's hired you they've told you go
get information from X Y and Z and give
it to us and do whatever you have to do
but for me interviewing has a different
kind of character it's about hearing the
unexpected I often say that if you know
what someone is going to say in an
interview don't bother talking to them
it's the not knowing what you're going
to hear what's going to be revealed that
makes it really exciting and
interesting in your Memoir you say none
of it's true it's as I imagined it I
cannot Define for you
where reality goes through the Secret
Door into fiction David really makes me
think about the nature of self-deception
about truth he's a character who
constantly undermines himself in his own
stories and tells us about the nature of
memory and storytelling what's the truth
what's memory we should find another
name for the way we see past events that
are still alive in us truth objective
truth is perceived by some absent third
party but otherwise truth is
subjective David endlessly questions
himself his motives what he believes the
actual veracity of what he says I've
never had an interview subject who will
tell me in the middle of telling a story
well you know this story is probably not
true but I believe
it I loved making this film I love
talking to him I'm a lucky camper in all
of
[Music]
this